dann wollen wir doch mal schauen
ich glaube bin jetzt schon weiß nie was
gewesen
ich glaube ich
perfekt sein wollen geile quali freund
jacob erste max muster frau h das meint
man
wie man hört nichts ich mag den chat mal
raus hallo freunde was gedacht wir
kommen zum stream wir werden backen
er hört man uns marco ist die mucke zu
laut zu leise und guck mal gold es
sollte sehr synchron seien nicht so wie
beim letzten mal schreibt mal ob alles
so funktioniert wie gedacht hast mein
und tatsächlich muss es auch machen
sonst ist die burg nicht so laut
das darfst du dich anderen weil sie uns
hören dies nicht glaubt oder hören die
uns dabei coletti streaming jacobi dass
der markt auf dem die kekse ja machen
wir sehr gerne hört euch alles passt vom
ton kleine muck gipfel klar ist perfekt
juni dank der synchron meist mehr musik
modells gut note gut oder bis in leiter
gibt man sonst erste mal kunst da will
ich glaube das sollte klar gehen
ich checke jetzt gleich noch mal das
handy kelly kommt gleich noch dazu max
kommt gleich noch dazu kommen noch
diverse coole leute und wird das tut mir
natürlich leid und da habe ich schon
eine verspätung aber ich bin ich
deswegen wird es immer so sein ihr könnt
es grundsätzlich auf eine halbe stunde
verspätung einstellen wenn ich sage dass
irgendwas irgendwann passiert
stärken stärken
tja nämlich macht ja ich mache die
mutter ein bisschen lauter ich habe das
gefühl man hört sie gar nicht ich freue
mich auch sehr auf kelly ich freue mich
auch auf kanye aber mehr liess das wider
was willst du was fink jacob
nein stephen hendry braucht keine mucke
ach hallo papa also mein vater ist
anscheinend auch im stream europa ich
hoffe es geht dir gut dass die minmetals
mich in den letzten tagen nicht gemeldet
habe aber wenigstens bekommst du so eben
was thommy mit wir backen jetzt kekse
ich würde die kekse natürlich lieber mit
meiner oma an deiner mutter backen
schuhe jacke rabatt und tritt als
profilbild
hast du dein vater sieht ice t entdeckt
mich aber ich weiß dass ich alle einfach
reinkommen so ich komme mir die haare
und warum wartet ihr jetzt guckt dass
volker selbst habt ihr nicht irgendwas
wurde wir konnten das live gucken aber
er kommt da nach dem chat und so das ist
das was auf youtube com 25 10 sekunden
später euro
beck auf krieg sehr gut ist kommt mit
optischen ein geschenk bekommt ja wann
fängt so an ich werde alles nur noch auf
install katar und liegt gut leiten und
das wird sich das mein vater zu gucken
ist ein paar tage nicht bei den
gemeinden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jacob s 21 schon fast ein opa
[Musik]
ich hätte so lange her vielleicht bin
ich hier 1000
[Musik]
vielleicht kannst einfach so vorbei
können richtig
hallo freunde was genau wir sind
mittlerweile live und quatscht die
kamera ist live kommt vorbei war nicht
mein neues iphone zu weiter der selbst
wenn du dich nicht meldet jetzt ich bin
20 irgendwas dem video kommt wenn ich
wieder geld habt das problem ist dass
die videos du mich immer so 150 euro
kosten
nicht so gut wenn dieses mittel riechen
dürfen wissensbasierte aber
plätzchenbacken kostet nichts
fast nichts wird hier gerade 1002
empfohlen hat ich habe ich schon gesehen
natürlich ist in schwierigkeiten sind
gesehen ich liebe es carrie 18 geworden
aber man hat heute geburtstag wenn ihr
lust habt
alle mo gratulieren wir können ja dann
rufen wir kunst mode das geburtstagskind
auch noch den hut auf geburtstag
ja jakob das machen wir doch machten das
leben als geburtstagskind das leben ist
doch aber ich wollte dich bitten
natürlich nur bei der kekse backen die
für dich als geburtstags kekse gedacht
sind unter leuten tragen so vorbeikommen
setzt und die fläche davon essen willst
oder das helfen willst deine eigenen
geburtstags kekse zu backen
[Musik]
ok
ja geil das freut uns sehr
kommt neben bei mir zu hause hast du
meine adresse also die kann natürlich
auch mitkommen aber nein ja aber du hast
meine adresse oder aachener straße 25
sehr gut ja ja ja einfach mal sehr gute
kelly möchtest du noch gar nicht kann
hier äpfel saft und wir finden dass ich
die küche nach wie vor mich komplett
ausgebaut hat arbeiten die leicht
gemacht und hier im livestream die
decken nicht eine küche auf
ich habe einen schönen und das ist sehr
gut
wir fangen jetzt erst mal kekse zu
backen wir haben keine form
womit auch sonst ich habe nochmal was
hatten wir mal zwei geschenke an ist
auch eine kamera und einen namen gemacht
maximus so wand so ok
ja ich auch nicht wieder aufzunehmen
ich liebe 1 guckt mal machen offiziellen
aber einfach nur am handy modells aus
den things i could macht ein video
fertig ernährung ganz schnell vorbei
ja sehr gut ja ich habe auch schon fast
vor müssten das system einfach die woche
jakob wurde ein letztes mal im stream
sehr dass ich jetzt mache sehr viel sehr
viel liebe bekommst du deine guten witze
was natürlich ein musical nachfolger
wird in den usa kommt für eine card kann
ich weiß es doch nicht das muss eine
karte unterwegs mit dem messer könnte
bleiben man ja das stimmt
vielleicht sollten debatte so ich fange
jetzt mal agierten kamen zusammen zu
[Musik]
in jedem video in leeden livestream habe
ich irgendwas mit vielleicht jetzt denn
entweder ist und nicht das allerbeste
warte mal ich muss sagen ich hab noch
nie so richtig keks also ich habe vom
markt zu beobachten aber
und auch gezwungenermaßen kekse aber es
ist gar nicht fest es muss eigentlich
einmal noch nach hause fahren bei der
homag jetzt machen wir euch das leben
schwer gemacht hat ist ja dumm wenn ist
das jetzt mein bruder ist schon nach
hause gefahren und habe schon mit der
kompletten die küche freuen uns klasse
dass so auch nicht
[Musik]
politik ist jetzt endlich wieder ein
paar kekse backen ich weiß hat ganz
schaffen wird eigentlich immer direkt
[Musik]
per kopf 66 oder ganz schwer
dieser markt ist selbst rudi pell ist
[Musik]
wir sollten das ist nicht aussagen
ich würde jetzt das maxx tt
die größe der golden boy ist dass wir
offiziell ja ja das klappt schon heute
ich glaube dann hat das heute in ihrem
video gesagt weil ich an diesen [ __ ]
reicht noch keine ahnung gehört so
weiter und natürlich mit sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
würde sich richtig auskennen mit dem
button wissen
bisher ist die wacklige aber die kommt
dass am freitag der winter wochenende
[Musik]
klosterfrau sonja koch zusammen ja ein
ganz beratung wahrheit überhaupt nicht
und ja ich sagen es ist eben hatte
jemand gefragt wie wir über etwas freuen
sehr gut finde ich wusste nicht ob es
mehr trainieren ein video irgendwas von
mira schwiegermama geprügelt und dann
wussten alle so okay aber irgendwann
nicht es ist nicht wahr
mein schönster frau wir hier am start so
weit ich muss jetzt nur mal draußen man
ja perfekt war
aber es kann nicht alles sein
das ist sogar von meiner mutter sogar
butter mehl salz ist das sogar darauf
verzichten weil sonntag ist völlig
natürlich nicht
[Musik]
perfekt ja es ist sonntag und ich bin so
kam das fenster zur nächsten tag musste
ich besser aber nächsten saison den
nächsten sonntag ist glaube ich einfach
nur ein guter wein dann so einige andere
wagen oder da haben wir sehr gut aber wo
ist das eine wg oder mutter alleine
durch moment jacobs zusammen wie gesagt
in der aachener straße 52 kommt alle
vorbei köln 50674 köln alle die gleichen
schwierigkeiten eine wichtige staaten in
schwierigkeiten sondern davon ist
mittlerweile zwei monate in dieser
probiert und gefühlt gibt es hier nichts
keiner von uns wohnt hier so richtig
gestellt wissen sie was die aufnahme
hier vernünftig bekommen müsste zeit
muss der anteil proben von max
so werden auch schon gesagt ich stehe
morgens auf geht s max und kommen abends
wieder nach hause im schlaf möglichst
trainer damals die hamann traumfrauen
[Musik]
nicht so richtig wäre das ist aber die
lena kommen weiß nicht was so wurde es
geht herr waterpark die sagen einfach
alles zusammen mischen kneten das zu
klein ist nein wir machen nur 250 gramm
mehl 52 jahren eher weiche butter
er will ich mehr weiß was sie werden
wieder junge ich kann halt nicht alles
auf anhieb funktionieren müssen die
nutzer allerdings man selbst das größere
teil von den beiden preisen und das
reicht auch reiche und 125 gramm könnte
überhaupt sehen was ich tue
sehr gut max mustermann frage stellt
fest wie viel es ist und dank für die
gute unterhaltung
jetzt ist der andere freunde der der am
nächsten donnerstag geworden
vielleicht kommt da passendes video
einfacher geworden am liebsten
ostdeutschen zweig falls alles bei 124
personen das waren 1 war aber vorher 112
109 gramm nicht schlecht ja nun vorbei
in den stühlen zu locken am markt da
hast du irgendwas zum plätzchen
dekorieren da so sträußen unter so oder
über milde zucker vanillezucker aber das
hätten wir auch noch einmal mutter
irgendwann zumindest wasserstoffperoxid
daran hätte ich nicht ja geil im moment
ja das war hat mir viel so ein video
junger 404 zuschauer ich liebe es
ja können kommt nettowert auch wieder
ich glaube nicht
heute ohne aber dafür gleich mit max der
ist ja quasi auf dem weg hierhin so ich
mache das jetzt mal ruft ist schon ganz
ehrlich nein also man hört euch nicht
wir brauchen hier noch und ich komme man
auch mal die katze ist aber auch nicht
schlimm
damit sind ja ohne geschmack aber dafür
mit haben wir erst noch testen
geil das sieht ja immer bei seinen krieg
ich möchte hier weiter sagte sie was
kommt jetzt
martin zuckerfreie lebensmittelfarbe
daraus zu ziehen sind
schöne bunte wagen ist ich hab das ist
es mehr dass ich habe meine mutter hat
weiterhin überlegen
ja es war ein kumpel von zu hause so die
post jetzt auch zwei damen nicht mehr
alles zusammen kommt kündigt vorgezogene
[Musik]
und den red morgen kommt ob das
witzigste video
[Musik]
obama wird sich wirklich halten was habt
ihr noch mal ihr könnt schon mal 250
gramm mehl und 125 gramm zucker geil
die erste station ich küsse dich mag es
gern so nicht war gar nicht mag ich
nicht aber ich kann dir sagen würde so
violent wurden wir waren ihnen gleich ja
ja geil würde ich mich am nächsten tag
noch da ich glaube auch sehr maximal
schon von direktor elmar geld lasse mir
mein cousin natürlich lasse harvey was
geht ab suchen sonderfarben werden es
lösen
18 ok
[Musik]
er ist die mutter eigentlich noch an
macht ihr haus kekse ja schön wär's alt
wochen ganz ehrlich leute die mucke noch
albums freunde ich brauche eure hilfe
ich weiß ich muss schnell das papier 250
gramm mehl mathematik und glaube ich 125
gramm zucker kommen sagt warum bewerber
an
wenn diese zahlen nicht exakt wird dann
ist man ganz normal gewirkt
frag mich 27 32 150 250 und 100 gramm
zucker warte dass es nur richtig
gefeiert werden
[Musik]
ein bisschen trostlos was wir sein muss
wenn sie nicht so sehr es passiert gar
nicht ordentlich
ganz schwer beschädigt
was dann noch kommt kaum nachkommen zu
können
verstand 75 x 100 meter das ist das ist
meins der zucker von mama kuh prix von
coop ist aber gerade im urlaub deswegen
haben wir klar nein die kontakte zu hey
tut mir sehr leid für uns ja jetzt
wieder läuft es wieder
also sollte
die qualität ist der geisteskranke ja
nach hatte ich auch nicht erwartet
werden
[Musik]
noch einmal hier schnell wenn wir besser
sehen
[Musik]
ja es tut mir leid ich wohl immer nur
unter vorwand leute in den stream weil
ich dem versprechen das man irgendwas
gutes macht und dann muss ich das
einhalten
ich bin wirklich nur wegen den keksen
hier sonst aber natürlich nicht so gerne
mit leuchtend
kelis in den dom gezogen das stimmt
tatsächlich der 18 jahre musste die
kekse konzentrieren wichtigste teil also
72 kannst du noch in einer rein schlagen
lässt ist das ganze ja perfekt
ich bedanke mich vielmals
[Musik]
ich freue mich sehr auf mein alter ich
küsse dich vielmals für fünf euro aber
dann kann ich bald vielleicht kein
stress doch wieder kastration gewesen
momentan bin ich noch so circa 1000 euro
mit youtube - weil es nicht so schlimm
ich habe das gleiche arbeit außen und so
viele der ist nur mehr arbeit weiterhin
schon fertig sodass wir machen euch
leute
[Musik]
jana hat auch gesagt jedes mal wenn die
bei max reinkommt sieht sich am rechner
und aber das ist es ist fällt ins feld
eigentlich mache ich nie irgendwas
übrigen mankell ich freiwillig zum
backen haben die fachleute dass ich sage
dazu müssten backen oder soll ich hasse
es eigentlich wirklich aber ich weiß ich
ja weil ich fand es langweilig finde ich
zum beispiel niemals selber kekse backen
aber wenn ihr das machte und dafür hält
der staat kann nicht kekse hey guck mal
schneller ist mein handy dann kommt ist
1 2325 zementiert ist auch der kauf von
seiner kreditkarte muss auf dem hof
eine karte überhaupt nicht was ich
eigentlich
das muss jetzt hat er jetzt geht's rund
ich küsse deine augen malley ja 37 warum
größten und oft angefragt wurde das wäre
wahrscheinlich so das nächste was mache
weil ich mit 45 und 42 weil ich schon
relativ großen gehaltsschema ja es wurde
auch sehr oft gefragt was soll ich denn
überhaupt nach gucken also alle zutaten
enthalten noch mal ja ok
davon haben wir halt nicht mehr
ja bitte frischhaltefolie ja komposition
selber ein stück 1 49 50 jahren
tatsächlich war dass die brüste nicht
direkt danach noch ein richtig wo wir
heute einfach mal jeden eine
kopfbedeckung aus die ich habe da am
ende müsst ihr sogar die schönste
kopfbedeckung von jakob mahl deshalb
weil viele sagen hatten
weit im futter nicht plötzlich im nehmen
sollen egal ist es wirklich egal es
kommt für eine halbe stunde jetzt noch
im kühlschrank dann wird digital wieder
rad ich sag's wie ist es eigentlich
schon ganz lange warten
ich bin die ganze nun überlegen ob man
den menschen dabei mir fällt nichts ein
bild ist zu leise pro ja nicht dass ich
gerade ein jahr kommt ich habe das
letzte mal aus versehen gemacht stehen
und ich habe alles nur scheiße
geschrieben immer bruder können den wir
lange mag geld geht es jetzt nicht geht
es richtig los und nation wie was ist
eine prise zu einer ja ja ja so mit
prise salz möglich ich habe mich immer
irgendwie drauf getroffen ja geil chase
noah der boss zeitung ich habe auf dich
gewartet dass du endlich jetzt mal
kommst warum wechselt jakob die ganze
zeit seine kopfbedeckung einfach
aufgrund von entwickelt dessen ich freue
mich schon wenn wir im hof ist jakob
weiß wie gute unterhaltung funktioniert
das ich küsse dich auch weil also kohle
vor yahoo und an alle anderen fotograf
thomas muster frau kennen jason bio des
maximus nach frauen los da ist es nur
man fragt sich die ganze zeit wer max
muster frau ist kennt weiß nein es
musste ja der trägt fragen wir die ganze
zeit was ich von da gehst uralt ich weiß
gar nicht was tagestourist er ist erst
mal eine sache ich sage so viel max
muster post in dieser wohnung dann kann
ich gesehen und wir können sie fast wie
das muster vor zu trennen haben wir
zugeschaltet vornehmen du hast gesagt
hosen backpapier ja
[Musik]
heja wir davon überhaupt nichts ist
einfach gehalten werden zurzeit sind
nicht dumm
wir haben keine zeit und wir kennen die
an einem mittel stellt er noch 20 rabatt
auf die norm selbst von der nein wir
sind förmlich beschließen
wir haben kein casting stream von dem
enormen nichts mitbekommen ich sage so
viel er weiß wie die engines lenkt aber
junge diskreditiert nicht gibt es keinen
abbruch
wie läuft es mit den affiliate links
deshalb auch zu fragen ist das projekt
war habe ich abzublasen falls angefangen
habe perfekt aber erst mal ein video
das sagen leute laptops und so aber ich
hab es dann leider nicht weitergemacht
wird er wohl ein und eingreift und mit
einem bringen
zwar ist krank aber soll ich letztmalig
in vollkommener vorgelesen und dann habe
ich den haben sich irgendwie nicht in
den kommentaren werden haben sie gesagt
das habe ich gestellt das hat mich
gestört ist und ich haben aber wenn sie
jemand einheit mit darüber bestellt muss
sagen ja geld das ich könnte guck ich
guck doch mal rein und gibt auch
aktuelle informationen aber wieso
trichter wir nicht gute guter einwand
aber sonntag 19 sei es ein bisschen
außerdem ist papa im stream deswegen
sind die kriegs und schuss gut dass die
ganzen die alten sohn echten von mir
bekannten leuten
du warst eigentlich was ja nicht mit in
sich
wir müssen aber eigentlich mal tritt mit
allen die so in köln dabei sind muss ich
auch mein ja sieben vielleicht nicht
unbedingt aber irgendwo wir
der junge spender mehr als 20 geld kann
es kaum erwarten dass max kommt weil wir
bald mal wieder in hamburg
aber in berlin wahrscheinlich kennt die
frage stelle ich jetzt nicht weil krieg
direkt wieder blasen würden habe ich
nicht gelesen
diesmal sind deine frage was machst du
ich muss kurz test läuft werbung
ich glaube ich habe keine ahnung wie das
funktioniert ich bin uns natürlich wenn
er sagt nur kurz auch das funktioniert
hat dass ihr gerade währung gesehen habe
alle die es benutzen sind natürlich rein
raus
[Musik]
ich hasse das was er einzelnen job wenn
ihr lust auf werbung hat
[Musik]
du hast ja deswegen auf die unsere es
weiter
ich muss jetzt noch etwas neues
warte mal kurz wenn man kurz lasst uns
mal schnell neues an die macht weil
jetzt eskalierte oder wir warten auf das
max kommt den platz sie haben mit dem
linken zusammen das würde mich freuen ja
tatsächlich
wir müssen mit jahren zusammen ja es
ärgert mich auch das mag so lange
braucht aber das ist einfach so dass
sehr unpünktlich
der ist nicht so wär ich auch ich warte
auf den sendung zu sendung läuft
weihnachten so bei euch ab also
eigentlich waren wir immer einen
skiurlaub aber das hat sich in den
letzten jahren irgendwie weiß ich nicht
so ein bisschen ist die entwicklung ein
bisschen zurück gegangen und häufiger
haben die einzelnen familien mit dem
immer gefahren sind dann weihnachten zu
hause gefeiert wie es jetzt dieses jahr
aussieht weiß ich nicht
bei penny und für dieses jahr ja du
wirst nicht sogar für mich ist das heißt
würde ich muss viel mehr geschenke sagen
ja wir schenken uns nichts sondern kann
die maximale geschenk und es hat sich
noch gekauft und sagt man will
das stimmt aber ich bin der schlechteste
die ich jetzt mache ich habe in meinem
leben meinen eltern wahrscheinlich drei
oder vier geschenke gemacht zusammen
also beide an beide insgesamt drei bis
vier geschenke zu weihnachten und
geburtstag zusammen ich bin sehr
schlechte sohn was das angeht könnte ich
fand es von ihr wisst doch gar nicht was
euch erwartet dass wir so verrückt was
diesen dezember noch passiert ist
erzählt der amazon gutschein ist glaube
ich mir meine eltern nicht so dass alle
geschenke aber gute idee
[Musik]
du bist in meinem zimmer findest du eine
jakob haye aber die hast du noch nicht
alle durch guck mal hinten im saal wo
sie mögen sich nicht ändern
[Musik]
ich glaube tatsächlich auch dass jakob
beste das ich ja das war auch richtig in
die wirkliche ist nicht schlecht aber
was ist eigentlich mit den plätzchen ja
die sind im kühlschrank nach 10 4 20
minuten
hier hinterlegen man hat sich einfach
ausgestaltung alter gefragt wie wir die
getränke kalt stellen und in die aktion
ja irgendwann hatte gefragt ob es besser
ist in der skischule skifahren zu lernen
oder mit freunden
ich bin grundsätzlich kein freund davon
dass eine freundin das beibringen weil
die dann mit beschissen sie zeit haben
für sich weil so ein schiefer siebels
teuer ist und wenn man heute hat die das
können dann ist es für die hybris
stressig dass leuten beizubringen also
gebt einen schießt das wasser der pilz
fragt ob das leben in köln besseres
essen sie nicht besser weiß kompakter
wurst so ich wohne ja es ist besser ich
bin halt in der stadt alle meine leute
sind eben jene art von fünf kilometern
zu erreichen und den sieben
grundsätzlich wenn ihm jemand wenn du
nicht mehr gegen jemand ist ja nicht aus
dem ort kommt mindestens 20 minuten
fahren wenn ich in die stadt gefahren
denn auch von gefahren nicht so fahrrad
oder hier ließ tatsächlich war ich in
köln meistens mit schnellem schnell von
a nach b zu kommen sind sie hier
[Musik]
was ist euer größter traum jacobs nicht
sagt wie es ist zeigt ein video drehen
ein eiskalter otto forscher zuvor 220
grundsätzlich keine vorsätze hat je
nicht ein
das handy lag bei euch meinen ab
schreibt das blatt
sonst was dich aus weil mir leid werden
klassisch alma mädchen der familie essen
und das fahrrad und mitgeschrieben
scheiße wünschte mir was zu weihnachten
aber ich weiß leider schon was bekommen
ein esstisch
er arbeitete mit geld allein an unseren
tisch sitzen nicht weil es ein
besonderer als tisch stuhl ist aber dass
auch ein bild ist wichtigkeit erstellen
wir alle wissen dass es für studis wir
können solche nämlich sagen nein ich für
richtig
anstatt wie gewandeten fest was ihr euch
zu weihnachten wünscht was was wünscht
man sich so etwas nicht
du denkst du ist irgendwie auch papa
dürfen besucher wieder mit der nase
jetzt auch nicht mehr so ganz genau und
ja da jakob darf auch auf dem stuhl
sitzen wenn ich nicht da bin
eine kamera das ist schon was die
geschenkt bekommen das sie sich wünschen
dass die kamera ist stabil sie mal gute
einstiegs kamera so die beste die ihr
einfällt als 6000 war schnell vor 6000
oder lumix auch talk harry potter fan
wird das tier auch einiges von das
problem immer weil ich etwas geschenkt
bekommen sie immer hassen und harry
potter rentenalter ich hoffe dass meine
ich glaube ich habe mein kunde weiß
nicht ob das christlich ist aber auch so
allgemein übels bock dass wir im
vergleich so ein großes lichten macht
jedermann zum geschenk nur bis zehn euro
oder so so etwas kleines dann treffen
wir uns einen abend alle zusammen in
japan zum zweiten am 20 vor oder am 19
mit allen
ich habe das geld können wir weihnachten
mit allem zusammen feiern sondern
könnten eigentlich zwei strecken hatten
und ich habe aber wenn wir richtig
übertreiben will und dann könnten halt
auch so ein raum
viele leute sind in dem wichtige
weihnachtsgeschäft nicht sowieso radikal
aber naja es nur im sommer sondern das
richtige groß waren ja wenn er alle in
der stadt wohnen zu youtube köln kräftig
zur weihnachtsfeier gebracht können
so also max könnte so langsam wirklich
mal kommen so langsam muss schon oder
sonderschulen hauptschule schon meist
gut 20 metern zur maschine sehr gut
sichern
ich habe schon ein bisschen angst für
sie ein paar leute inspiriert dazu dass
es zwar nicht war die international
agieren lassen und man kann echt nichts
schlimmes nachweisen punkt zu machen
weil alles andere kann ihnen also
wirklich schief geht und der ist schon
ich guck mal
deswegen ist was man dass diese ganzen
leute von zu hause schicken wir denn da
finde ich küsse dich natürlich natürlich
aber das mit dem tätowieren ist wirklich
so eine sache ich habe ich bin zufrieden
mit alte tosic haben aber ich merke halt
schon dadurch dass ich einmal warum
haben dass ich nicht so selbert studiere
komplexität jubel seiner fans institut
will dann ist es so wie letztes mal gut
sich montags morgens joggen kann ist
eine tormaschine haben danone ist ja man
lasse ich ja die noch nicht einfach so
auf man bald ändern
ich würde gerne noch mal ein bisschen
mehr von sich hören aber ich weiß nicht
geschenke waren schon nahe
du sagst es dann auch noch mal eine gute
idee nun ja nach weihnachten kommt der
leitung schnell schon silvester und
liefer bringt ihr euer silvester
das war nicht meine frage meine frage
war zwar in fragen der scheiße
ja vorfall hat auf seiner party
das ist kein von wolfen küche das
erklärt vielleicht auf eine kurzformel
jan schindler schindler eben was wären
sagt den ihn nicht machen wollt gute
frage ich habe ich glaube ich noch nicht
ich habe das gefühl diese rabatte machen
bild davon dass piloten zum mega trucks
sind aber eigentlich sieht der alltag
von denen sondern was ich nicht jemanden
der so lokführer ist oder sogar komplett
ähnlich also ich mal sagen das ding und
dann fliegen sie einfach zwei stunden
sitzen auf demselben motto hallo
[Musik]
die hat mir meine adventskalender fertig
habt ihr natürlich sehr genau geraden
aber ich bin gerade am live stream
wenn du mich live sehen will dann kann
es auf youtube kunden der papa war ja
gerade ihm auch schon drin
neue aufregung
ich habe keinen mehr soll ich machen da
habe ich nicht gesagt ich hab mich
einfach nicht mehr so leben der day4 mit
seiner mutter telefoniert innerhalb von
einer halben stunde wellen
ich habe schon gleich am erwarte ja in
einem bahnhof
ich habe heute meinen ersten advents
türchen aufgemacht haben gesagt wir
danken rucola aus meinem rad bands
können aber es war der 19
aber man kann sich gleich zurückrufen
stadt weimar kommentare das jetzt
wirklich einzeln entscheiden wenn jakob
den denn endlich mehr aussetzen sollten
da kommt meine mutter hat gesagt alles
was doppelt ist das in den ganz kleinen
das 1 4 durch das bedeutet davon lief
und von ricola für dich sabine hier
fehlt vielen dank termin im vorjahr sehr
gutes jahr konnte das sind leider nicht
mehr aussetzen wollte weil das in dem
sand gegangen
ja wir wollen zusammen
bei uns ist ja gut fahrlehrer ja schau
dort also mitgebracht und da kommt
zusammen nein
ob dein verriet harry potter qualität
sagt man sicher sagen ja mein
lieblingscharakter ist weil ich ja schon
des öfteren den läuft gesenkt die west
africa tricks wenn deutscher wenn ihr
mal bellatrix sind wirklich zur folge
haben 882 50 der ohne witz bezaubert da
so ein bisschen rum als gerland
du wolltest übrigens könnt ich habe noch
kein stuhl zu weihnachten ist am ende
doch treffen ich habe kein
[Musik]
der start der stream wird natürlich
gespeichert so widersetzte und könnt ihr
immer anschauen auto an bord safer sax
wie es ist seid ihr nicht gefahren bin
der teig ist fertig sie hätte mich ja
aber ford gefahren bin war ich nur noch
meine mama warum welche auftritt von
köln nach siegen will
ich bin ich auf meinen harbort und du
schnell dass sie immer so wird
geschichte
[Musik]
was macht der forschung oder um italien
der bruder hat mich auch noch anders
knapp durch geprüften durch
ich bin nicht durch gefahren aber es war
sehr knapp
natürlich bestens bestanden überhaupt
nicht
investition und finanzierung 123 g 23
glaube ich dir wegschiebt ich habe diese
aufgabe dann jegliche kauf bewertungen
nicht hinter auszuziehen oder es
verzögerung für die zange und müssen uns
da was geht ja rennens ein
marco ist nicht los dass hier bestimmt
sondern einzig an
[Musik]
krone was diese stiftung für korea ist
ja echt gut
naja mein hobby ist aus omaha gewollte
wahrscheinlich wissen es ist keine marke
nichts ist hier lagen zwischen wir da
sind ein paar die mir so sind wir dann
kannst du den chat wiederum letztmals
musste vorher das fragen wir uns ja auch
die ganze zeit dass selbst die ganze
zeit frau vielleicht auch nicht mehr das
ist ich frage mich schon die ganze zeit
mit meinem zimmer sind sehr dass ich
weiß was ich habe im unterland foto
konzerten einfach soll kommentiert
münchen sparkassen oder wiesenbrüter
tolles blau wenn die guten halb neun
weitere sorge dort wie er echt richtig
verstehe ich nicht bei den damen in
rechnung gestellt hast und ich ja schon
mal so ein kleines malheur das ein oder
andere bieter ist schon in meinem
macbook aber ich habe nicht mehr so der
typ der da sind wir dann doch jakob ist
tatsächlich wirklich verlieren
ich finde das übrigens so ein bisschen
beängstigend dass mein vater hier zu
schauen ich nicht das glaube ich dir
müssen genau
ja und jetzt müssen
ich bin jetzt angekommen bei date und
wir machen ja schneller jetzt ja gott
und der kamera des live streams von
mental ist glaube ich ein paar tagen ein
pater bleibt ich brauche dich
es ist doch dass herr juncker noch das
technisch yakubu prix damit ihr wisst
ihr dass die leute freude
leisten sie behelfen von ganz oben wo
man werde richtig ja das stimmt
ich komme bald nach hause und dann mache
ich mit oma kekse und am main stream mit
meiner oma
[Musik]
max karagoz unterhalten
ich war natürlich das gerede der wind
fände ich habe übrigens ich habe
übrigens speise farben mit gail und
response blog alter überhaupt macht es
reicht meinte jetzt musst du die durch
durchgehend durch vierteilers und jemand
was einfärben wollen wir das hier
freundschaft noch einläuft excel machen
dass das bin ich da sehr verwundert
gewesen wären
hast du die erste story nicht genommen
ich habe allerdings ebenso aufkommen
kann freut eine qualität von reichen
wieder das vielleicht noch zehn jahre
natürlich wir haben technisch mag gute
ist ja auch der outfit dass jemand mich
irgendwie ja okay kommt mir tragen hier
den pulli mit energy und morgen mit
alten regimes und zur an leute die
speisen habe meinen besten max muss man
vom vierten einzel entscheiden wenn wir
uns auf ihn einfach nur geil
da sieht man wie schnell die vorzüge der
vor dem kopf ins tor fand
aber kannst du mir bitte speise farbe
geben weil der mörder seiner
trainingskollegen harry potter all ihren
geil ich hoffe das ist nicht die die ich
auf
wie geht es euch sehr gut sehr schlecht
vielen dank für den sektor nicht wenn
hier ostring scribe neue abonnenten
welche übrig für beide zertifikate
[Musik]
schock wenn ihr glück habt macht max
muster vor wollte noch ein auftritt aber
ich kann es wirklich nicht garantieren
deswegen brauchen natürlich geil und ich
bringen dass man sich bringen
dead space ist sieht man halt nicht eben
zu den verschiedensten farben natürlich
sein dass gleich kurbad waffen transit
ob der tumor yahoo weil man sieht man
sie zählt natürlich habe auch nicht
davor gescheut siehst du da gucke ich
naja sind perfekt
[Musik]
was von hart aber zu teenie gar nichts
von beiden ja ich bin der einzige der
hier seine hände ist das gelenk das kann
man noch mal schnell doch safe so übel
da war ich wohl nicht die richtige farbe
darauf sich die option aber ich habe das
glaube ich nicht so super schlugen
roberto jessica ihren ja ich weiss man
einmal und erst nicht ans handy ja es
tut mir leid gestern war lost haben wir
sind früher nach hause gegangen und
haben uns leid nächstes mal wieder was
wirklich so packte das freut mich auch
dass einen das einfachste das geld was
schon mal auf dem weihnachtsmarkt diese
nein nicht aber und es war sommer
zweimal kopf einmal zuviel ein
das ist vielleicht nicht so
man kennt sie den pakistani wanderer zur
auto von die irgendwann fahren das macht
[Musik]
ja ich weiß nicht welcher ich küsse dich
fünf euro die hände sehen sie sagt jetzt
[Musik]
lassen wir das etwas einstecken roth
jakob
das sieht gut aus 16 uhr 1 im auge
kardinal gefärbt ja ich denke er
gebrauchen
[Musik]
lesen ist mir viel zu schnell fuhr und
diesen lieblingsrapper nun ja diverse
verschiedenste carlito könnt euch kesha
mit tik instagram instagram hat noch
nichts hochladen aber ich werde euch
wenn ihr jetzt seid ihr dran liegt
[Musik]
fortan
der räumt heute auf das auto
ganz gut getan sagt max muster vor auch
max muster frau nein aber die
theoretisch vielleicht schon weil max
muster aus schon sie wirklich sehr gut
aus und dann wenn man dann mit einer axt
als seine mutter vor wird es schon
länger oder sie sind so gerade bekommt
weil das sagt aber irgendjemand in den
tschechischen der ist klug das ist sehr
gut mit dem taylor swift ja genau wie
selena gomez traum ist michael
ordentlich ja keine ahnung brauchen
sagte er so geht's ja die ganze zeit
hier weil ich den holen will
[Musik]
diesmal wieder aschaffenburg nothomb ich
wäre gern noch mal aschaffenburg aber
bald schon da und 2
das doppelte fünf songs 2009 10 auf 1
wenn das co2 alles vom blumen alles von
533 auf drei mit von ländern zu dir herr
charlie bentley ist aber andere liest
nun platz fünf neu einrichten
ja tatsächlich einmal oben der song auf
platz 23
[Applaus]
henning sostmann ich kürze deine augen
sind krass das ist nix erster kommentar
unter jedem video
ich würde dich so gerne in echt
kennenlernen meinem totaler der quere
natürlich absoluter ihrem gott aber der
einzige wahre ihren gott bist du kannst
machen
das ist wirklich real tor das ist der
beste größter bis superstar moderator
marc hat die besondere talente
im kopfstand ist das recht eure mama
lässt sich erkannt na ja nicht so ein
nudelholz und ich war heute nacht bei
mir frauen
[Musik]
also irgendwie das gefühl es müssen so
fest
noch kritischer sein perfektes schlag
das immer noch zu wenig mehr traut ist
der ton also bei euch wenn herr lass
dich komplett aus hey das ist nun einmal
das ist noch eine abgestimmte busse
wurde von glas und flaschen
[Musik]
zweimal schon vorher zweimal für die
rolle und irgendwas spd ist im kontext
wie vor den kronen
[Musik]
ich hasse es hey leute was also ein
polizist sehr gut wer dann geht es gibt
super modern ja ich glaube resources gab
es hilft aber wirklich dass ich jetzt
wirklich vom einkommen könnte mich mal
was du aber noch mit zwei vielleicht
kommt noch sehr viele andere länder
reisen heute die werbung ist draußen
max sorry dass ich wieder gute hatte
nach recherchen einer texte besser
machen ja klar kannst du kriegst du pont
ausständig sie macht ihr jetzt muss man
haben
die chance tolle gesehen hätten noch vor
zwei tagen
es stimmt natürlich noch eine das video
am nächsten tag so fit sein kannst das
omega sterne frühstück einfach soll wie
immer man kann ja gar nicht sehen dass
wir backen
das ist nicht so schlimm eine
peinlichkeit was wir hier machen
so konnte ich sehen was wir backen ach
so ja darum geht es auch nicht es geht
eigentlich nur um dich
das geht es darum bewerben nicht
vermissen
und jetzt sind wir einfach nur froh das
zu hören eigentlich ist dieser ganze
leistung max gewinnt und muster vor und
die braunhaarige werden hier auch echt
überhaupt wollen dann seid gespannt
passt sehr gut auch verpassen haben
haben auf jeden fall sollen die max
muster erkennt und entlarve die person
nur gewinnt das gewinnt und nicht boxen
kurz für star wars clone hat die 14
er ist als erstes dann irgendwann land
hat gewonnen macht man das mädchen das
mädchen als sklave
das war eine lava wenn wir sie kein
gehör
doch wer jetzt als erste jemand schreibt
max muster frau ist richtig richtig der
herren mit kapuzen sind kurz verweist
sie alle schreiben für jemand anstellen
das webmuster frau vasco ist wird das
mal klosterfrau stifter dies möge ich
würde das aber nicht so viel action
der italiener hat nicole du hast recht
jetzt haben bestimmt die italiener
hatten sich eigentlich kaum zugeschickt
bekommen denn die schlechten wird ist
das eigentlich selbst ja dass ich das
war meine mutter hat keinen nirgendswo
hingelegt haben wo man sie findet alter
die dummen ich überlege ob ich genial
wenn du mir was man stellt das wir
machen können doch nicht vielleicht was
ein
wir können ein kreise und sonst macht ja
ja ich weiß nämlich die gesehene
plastikflasche getroffen
der unterlegene stock formiert
plastikflaschen
wir haben
vielleicht
[Musik]
schon bis hin zu groß
ja keiner hinter ein kleiner die abwehr
gefunden
wir haben einfach nicht das umgesetzt
was ihr werkzeug ja wir folgten darunter
ein stern
ja ich mache das ist das was man hat
schon bestimmt nicht was ein
unangenehmes gefühl das wird so geil
funktioniere nicht sagte jedoch
enttäuschend war schlecht
wir haben die stimmen sind weil der
geilen dann lass es mich dass mit socken
aus einfachen leute die sich da einfach
noch offen wie viel mehr ich dann auch
mal machen wenn du mir und ich brauche
jetzt einen tipp wir haben ja 624 leute
die uns helfen könnten
die sollen mal googeln oder hat sprach
persönlichen erfahrungen zu rüsten
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist ein ewiger sein weiß
was hab ich schon
[Musik]
schnaps lassen weil er nicht da ich
möchte gerne wieder irgendwas gutes
sagen und schreiben
habt ihr mich braucht sehr gute
gespräche
die straße zum haus schreiben hatten wir
schon mal geil und ich wollten unsere
mutter fällt
hey mann hatte nicht so lange kneten und
jetzt dazu werden dafür dass gute leute
das hier ist perfekt
welches der rehab das ist perfekt ich
mache genau das was max neulich in
seiner story gemacht hat weil mich das
wirklich interessiert in meiner
analytics steht dass 70 prozent der
leute die zuschauen bei 18 seit über 18
oder seid ihr unter 18 bitte das ist
unter nachkommen andere sehr coole
tragen
ich kann es kaum abwarten sieht man euch
an bord zu bekommen
danach ans werk
1831 16 und 28 16 15 18 17 22
deswegen halte ich glaube tatsächlich
dass das fast dahin kommt was man
analytics mehr sagen weil davon gehen
auf der seite auch zum essen
das war so ein ding kann man jetzt noch
mal eine kleinere schneiden kann man so
spitzbuben mädchen hat sich gelohnt dass
ich mir
mit dem tag gegeben unsere ausgelastet
bin ja ja ist aber es könnte es
tatsächlich hinkommen mit zeig mir wo es
neuschnee das geht doch so gemeint aber
ich glaube das kommt echt sehen mit den
anderen musik für sie gemacht dass dank
der jana ist glaube ich doch mal oh ja
meine beste zeit kommt ich glaube im
chat in der schnell
hallo ja mal bist du da da kannst du
mich hören
ich vermisse dich sehr im stream
ich sag's wie es ist natürlich auch
freunde wie weit sind werden hier mit
dem mann machen weil sie dabei hey das
ist hier so eine scheiße ich habe den
sohn verplant dass ich nicht mal
geschafft habe
sollte aus staub zu organisieren lassen
lasst uns jetzt einfach irgendwelche
kreise und formen machen unserem hd
offen
[Musik]
und man feiert verhindert und jetzt kann
man noch einmal so in dem werk kassel
chad ja ich mache seit ich mache jetzt
geschieht wenn fragt sie bitte nicht die
pixar
ich habe auch bessere pläne sehr gut so
besser biermarken
[Musik]
kurz vorm haus ab welchen klub kann die
empfehlen
[Musik]
danke ich nicht große bastian video
fertig
ausgenutzt und breit
okay du hast ja ein
das reicht
[Musik]
jakob in köln geboren natürlich bin ich
das jedenfalls den ganzen anderen halt
doch ein meine 1
motor einzelzeit wird auch in köln
geboren ist einfach alle einzelschritte
meiner sicht hat sich doch diesmal ist
übrigens ist nicht der kommerz
ehrlichkeit dumm da kommt hat sie bitte
aufwendig zu beleidigen
[Musik]
doch wenn ich die flasche nur gerade 1
aber ehrlich sein
doch du bist du auf die bühne gehst du
mich ich dachte wir dpa wer ist der
ordentliche hre von euch ja gefordert
das gleicht sich aus
erstmals konnten tatsächlich sind
tatsächlich macht jakob sie welche
schilder sind grund solle dennoch was ja
ok herzen sind so besonders machen ein
weltklub beamter ist es nicht wissen
dies ist den räten zehntausender gesagt
ich mache jetzt einfach irgend welche
form ist und einfach noch tätigen vorbei
keinen pelz nein bitte nicht mag
doch nein doch wohl nicht ihr
das nicht das problem
einzelne synapsen nicht cool aber das
aber keine smartphone welches größer ist
[Musik]
keine fußballer fußball fans ja alles
schon
[Musik]
die pace wird wird was macht ein jahr ab
morgen wieder uli ja natürlich morgens
montag also kommt man diesem montag ist
unter tage sagt runter und man sieht es
aber gar nicht mal so ein bisschen zu
weit führen dass wegen der besseren
überraschung zu sein ist kein problem
wie habt ihr das gerufen kommt ja
natürlich max brod lassen wie kann ich
mein training sportgruppen wie kriegt
sie den jahre was ist am ende
[Musik]
ich mache ja noch lange hält an die
seite
[Musik]
nach basketball mail auf ihrem weißen
nach dem schwarzen körperlich habe
einmal ein verweis dafür bekommen dass
ich das beim touren magnesium auf meine
mannschaft und wird
handabdrücke auf den rücken von dem
mitschüler aber das ding war der leber
[Musik]
hallo der sound ist scheiße aber ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich glaube man
hat uns glaube ich und in schlechten
sound aber sehr gut dass ich da
natürlich ein auge getroffen
schon wieder da ja sehr
okay ihr passiert geist kranke dinge
aber ihr könnt halt nicht sehen
[Musik]
jetzt wird das gleiche nur noch auf die
alten aktivieren das war ein bisschen um
gefahren damals funktionierte alles
doppelt und doch im sommer hat und
doppelt so jetzt sollte wieder alles
funktionieren
[Musik]
es sollte doch wieder alles
funktionieren freundes mehr geben
marx ja man will deine geschichte zu
ende
[Musik]
okay die gesamte gelände gleich ich kann
nicht aus meiner stelle nochmal meine
geschichte passiert die leute können
hier sie angehen und beim pflanzen
nützlich
mein tipp bitte ich kümmere mich um den
ok meine folge nutzte die geschichte
trug sich dazu ich war sportunterricht
und wenn ja was die jungen mann
verdummen man tote und magnesium um den
grip an den banken zu verbessern
westfalen
ich habe ja schon mal metern die hand
gemacht und habe nicht immer so ein
bisschen scheiße gebaut in der schule
und dann habe ich mit diesen magnesium
hätten mitschüler so auch des schwarzen
t shirt aus den dritten und zwei
handpuppen dann sollten wir uns zu der
reihe aufstellen weil der lehrer
irgendwie sowas sagen wollte oder so
dann ist also hinter die schüler
gelaufen so dass er vor allem rücken
sehen konnte und die stadt um gelungen
so sieben plätze weiter von dem typen
wochen wir kollegen von mitschülern und
er sieht das so dass er magnesium und
sagst du direkt oder markt vorweist
einfach weil er wusste dass ich es
gewesen sein muss und ich meine damit
das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert sie
rebellieren
also das reicht jetzt
das ergibt der wasser heraus man ja auch
wenn das so ist muss man werde deshalb
bei den pensionen deshalb trotzdem
basterds ist orientiert ja aber ich kann
schon verstehen dass lehrer ich mochte
ich habe mich auch nicht gelaufen ist
ist eigentlich lieber in mir mein gott
echte all die wende und da ist noch was
kelly das schreiben die leute ein
kleines nicht die klose gerade eben ist
das bild wieder ankam
hier müssen was wissen wir ja würde
nicht dumm da die dadurch soll man die
story hat sich schlüssiger gangster ja
das sollte zuerst sollten was neues hier
wurde bekommen weil ich angst der
unterschrift andere behandlungen fast
keiner gefragt aber an der story durch
bereich bekommen haben haben abend in
meinem leben hast und verein kommen ich
glaube sie sich für körperlich am ende
einmal habe ich mit schüler von duncan
bilder von mir ein verweis bekommen weil
er irgendwie ich recht mal unterricht
oder scheiße gebaut hat aber der lehrer
war so ein bisschen fahrplan kunstlehrer
und dann hat der kunst wieder dass ich
auch geschrieben so nahmen klasse dass
er diesen verweis als erinnerung dass er
den abschied
und dann bin ich aber brechen werde mit
kollegialen gefühlt habe wenn ich so
vorgegangen wird man kurz mit zum lehrer
hast du das sehr passt das so auf alibi
und habe mein bild aber auf den zettel
gelegt was ist die nahe kommen
abgeschrieben hat und so dran geheftet
und habe den mitgenommen weil man
plattformen und dort verschwinden lassen
so weit so gut so ich war richtig
richtig ehrenmann und so habe man zudem
geregelt
bis mich dann mit einem anderen
mitschüler gestritten hatten das mädchen
muss wenn du siehst das war nicht okay
hierfür habe ich alles reden aber ich
habe dir fans medias das new york wenn
du das siehst kommt nicht nach draußen
am main mussten hören können der chor
der der wasserschlacht
[Musik]
ja das ist doch nur das training erst
einmal vorbei kommt
wir sind schon bist du dumm wird egal
aachener straße 230 nach schon die ganze
zeit gesagt okay weil naja wie auch
immer das geld muss man anfangen
da kann doch nicht passieren der straße
32 ich sag's euch immer wieder das ist
reinicke das ist nicht unser zweites
zuhause kette und ich liebte ich hab
dich auch nicht kommen wir haben die
kinder die wir heute kennen und fotos
schicken
wir müssen wir machen daraus und kraß
wir sehen echt ziemlich anders aus
[Musik]
kleine
fast 30 prozent der autofahrer dass wir
auch mal ein ende
das ist auf jeden fall das beste und ich
bin gespannt wir sehen gleich
funktioniert aber es ist sehr gut
was sagt ein original weiß wäre das ist
doch noch zu knacken sind schindler der
stadt viel schöner schein
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so konnte die nachricht sogar zum lachen
gebracht
hh damals war jeder logischen video
sortierte kommt auch um mit kennwörtern
macht jakob vergleich mit nein der held
vielleicht an dazu führt das zentrum
morgen 16
das beste video sehen das würde das
videos nicht anders als sonst aber wir
machen auch denkst alle gehen da ich
mitgucken ja übermorgen video-chat alter
besser gesagt ja freunde geschrieben
max ist wieder alles gut mit used by
dave macht videos mit dir und luca
gesagt ich hab dich kennengelernt als
ich mit lucas luhr so warten wir
eigentlich hersteller zudem brauche die
telekom muss hier bleiben aber ich muss
mir sagen was sie bestellen finden
nicht mehr so lange 75 fertig sagt es
ist zu sagen ist es halt so hat es das
messer so gefährlich in der hand dann
schreiben wir es uns absolut dafür
ich gebe euch einen kaffee ja ja die
sächsischen natürlich wie es ist kann
ich durch bestes gab weder welt diese
aber auf dichtigkeit effizienter
verwendet das ist power aber heißt die
entweder ich gucke nach unten oder ich
konzentriere mich im recht bin sehr
aufgeregt dann kommen die zum vorschein
was war das peinlichste was sie googeln
musstest jakob kuba eigentlich müssen
lernen
vielleicht klingelt ja ich gehe auch
davon aus dass gleich klingen ja an der
straße 32
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der hammer kommen sie
kommen sie okay naja ich darf ich glaube
die kekse sind fertig dass diese niemals
ob nicht doch schon das riecht aber wie
lange brauchen kekse nicht lange
rathausstraße 39 ja 19
mega köpfe der ja komm lass gut sein
bruder lieber käse paradies
sechs wochen so viertelstunde ja okay
dann grenze sprechen
zehn bis 15 minuten warten drei minuten
sind die durch und dann brauchte ja aber
nur weil walter schwulen vielfalt ist
noch mal kurz
ich könnte jetzt dabei sein wie comment
war das stück
[Musik]
das hat
daniela kraft weiter
seit 2004 ist stamp jahren immer mehr
leute seid live dabei
das ding war das geld somit das video
soll man nicht nein bewegst du ja genau
das foto und was uns das bild sehr gut
ausfüllen der nehrener muttersprache
klappt mache
[Musik]
direkt ich bedanke mich anziehen freunde
auf unsere worauf florian bohn beste
herrscher des computerkonzerns tun würde
da würde ich würde das auch richtig wenn
tiere nicht vom platz flog heute mit
jerusalem heute mit den jungs cottbus
elf lohn autor kommt vorbei fährt die
ganze areal florian rapp kaum vorbei
wenn es vorbei ist wird alles anders
werden anders gibt eine raucht video den
sommer erwartet wort zu pflegen
die italiener sollten weil ich sage es
ist so
wann kommt ein neues dave erklärt
hoffentlich nehmen diese scheiße
langweilig ja ganz genau morgen dass wir
werden aber unklar
nein neuen made by von gail kelly bistum
müde ich weiß versteht nicht zu packen
jetzt schreibt alle mal keinen chat
führen und kam nicht ganz gezielt schon
gecheckt dabei die fresse kälbern machst
du da einen junkie chen besoffen bisher
anscheinend gespräche gasthaus ich sage
[Musik]
dass wir sind hammer dieses internieren
ja der ist dass sich vor schlechten das
heute so nah heißt doch sehr guten ja
das wollte ich vermeiden
die leute sind eher gibt noch mal so ein
ding wir haben doch da umso mehr da oben
wo ja da einen der beiden fächer in le
mans tritt um so
mit dem heute ganz kurze haare ganz kurz
was einstellen
[Musik]
naja
freunde es wird probiert das war max
aktion einfach dieses übels krankheit
bei conti nun ist klar die sind heiß
aber geschmacksrichtung
[Musik]
die roten trikots fleisch werde ich
überhaupt nicht so fern von sind gar
nicht so kennt ihr druck sehe ich nicht
so
[Musik]
zuckerguss oder schokoglasur haben wir
alles nicht das budget verteidigen dann
aber dass das budget machen hier
[Musik]
ja dieser die youtube-seite beim zweiten
mal vermachen dabei so machst du musst
dann ja nicht der fall heißt also es
muss schnell gehen
ja
[Musik]
geld brauchst du weidmann blickt schon
sehr geil wenden wenn street erwarten
wir müssen jetzt noch nicht
verabschieden hattet ja es war sehr
schön ist es war sehr geil da wirklich
die besten wird die beste ich danke euch
für alles
euro - mit youtube deuten manchmal jetzt
rein und nicht direkt auch auf morgen 16
uhr gesehen